Toes are just so weird, I mean have you ever
looked at them, they’re so stubby and useless,
why can’t we have cool grippy toes like
chimpanzees?
Hey guys Julia here for Dnews.
This little piggie went to market and this
little piggie is...well, it makes no sense.
It looks like nothing else in the animal kingdom.
Seriously. have you ever just looked at your
toes and thought why?
Well, Hallo Pjotter asked us how our toes
evolved.
And that’s a good question.
Toes likely evolved from the same bones that
became fins, wings, or hooves in other species.
The dominating scientific theories are that
fingers and toes are exclusive features of
tetrapods, or vertebrates with limbs.
But according to one study, toes may have
evolved even before fish left the ocean.
The study, published in the journal Nature,
found 385 million years ago, a fish named
Panderichthys, had homologous bones to our
fingers and toes.
Either way, phalanges are over hundreds of
millions of years old.
Human toes, specifically, are a little newer
to the scene.
Of all the other living primates, we’re
the only ones that exclusively walk upright
on two legs.
Other primates, like chimps, have little grippy
feet and ours are just kind of weird looking
in comparison, but research shows they used
to be grippy back in the day.
According to a study published in the journal
Foot and Ankle International, our ancestors
Australopithecus afarensis, which lived 3.5
million ago years ago, had feet that looked
remarkably like a chimpanzee’s!
Fast-forward to homo habilis an ancestor who
lived 1.76 million years ago.
And her feet looked a lot like ours do now.
We traded in our opposable toe for shorter
toes overall, and gained an arch in our foot.
What happened in that interim?
Well in short, our ancestors came down from
the trees and started walking on land.
As our foot evolved to support walking on
the ground, we started moving faster and faster,
eventually learning to run.
These changes forced our feet to evolve to
deal with both balance and propulsion in a
highly efficient way.
Basically, our feet became more springy and
shock-absorbent.
And there's a study to back this up in the
Journal of Experimental Biology, showing basically,
these toes are made for running.
The researchers created models which showed
that longer-toed individuals do more mechanical
work to stabilize their joints and ligaments.
This means they use more energy to run the
same distance as shorter-toed people.
This supports what’s called the “endurance
running hypothesis” or the idea that our
ancestors were really good at running long
distances in order to chase down and wear
out prey.
In this kind of hunting style, those with
long toes are evolutionarily selected against
because it takes them more work to do run
down the same prey.
The researchers also found shorter toes might
reduce the risk of injury meaning, long-toed
people would expend more energy to run the
same distance, AND run a higher risk of injury
while doing it!
So, our toes, while short and stubby, maybe
have evolved to help us run, keep our balance,
and absorb impact.
So, the next time you go for a jog thank your
toes, even though they can’t help you climb
trees anymore.
The weird thing though I keep hearing about
toes, is that our pinky toe is going away,
that we’re evolving out of it.
It’s just a useless vestigial structure.
But that’s more old wives tale than anything
else.
As for one of our other useless lumps left
over from evolution: the appendix, it might
not be so useless after all, Tara has the
whole story, right here.